there's a twitter thread uh going viral
i i forget the guy's name so forgive me
but he talks about why they why why the
left is freaking out over the parental
rights and education bill so much
now there's a meme where someone says
it's not rocket science guys they're
just evil and they want to do that aaron
mcintyre let's give him credit yeah but
but he's wrong and uh there's a great
threat about this that james lindsay had
retweeted and i forgive forgive me to
the the podcast host who posted it
because i forget his name i don't know
if you guys want to try and look it up
but uh what he was saying is
this what's happening
um and i think he's saying it's
intentional his revolutionaries need to
sever the relationship between child and
parent yes and so what they do is they
first in secret will start explaining to
the children why they're evil and bad
and why they should feel guilt and shame
once they've sufficiently made these
kids hate their own identity and their
parents identity they offer up
alternative identities you can now be
one of these oppressed minorities pick
and choose you can be anything it's all
a social construct then when the parents
finally find out and are shocked by
what's happening
the kids are already so deeply and and
uh entrenched in the ideology
that the teachers can then say see we
told you they'd come at you they you you
could only trust us yeah and at a
certain age you want to be against your
parents because as a teenager you want
to be your own identity so it's very
useful to leverage that kind of a
natural social uh but so age group i
don't i don't i don't know if i could go
so far as to say there's an intentional
cabal of you know people doing this but
i can say
that
whether whether it's a conspiracy or
just it's happening it is happening this
way
and the way uh this gentleman describes
it is it's because there's a lot of
teachers who are following a curriculum
that seems to be empathetic to children
who are experiencing some issues and so
they're going along with it but i think
the important point why is the left so
hell-bent on lying about what this bill
is calling it don't say gay well the
bill also
prevents teachers from talking about
heterosexual marriage and traditional
relationships why do they need to frame
it this way the one thing they're truly
threatened by
the bill does not prevent teachers from
talking to children about being gay it
prevents them from doing it in secret
they can't tell the kids don't talk to
your parents the teacher many of these
teachers are saying they're going to do
it anyway all right if you're an adult
and you wanna have sexual conversations
with five to nine year olds and you say
don't tell your parents i'm gonna go
ahead and assume you're grooming these
kids 100 or worse what else are you
supposed to assume i mean that's the
most it's not being uncharitable that's
the most reasonable possible assumption
and you mentioned that they want to
sever children from their parents and
it's very true it's debatable whether
there's a concerted effort but you see
this in media all the time the family
unit is consistently attacked and
basically every television program the
father is always a complete [ __ ] who
can't do anything right and that's
because if you want to go after any
structure you start by attacking the
authority and so it's been seared into
an entire generation of people if not
two or three generations on some level
that data is stupid and not to be
respected and made fun of and i think
part of it is just a result of the fact
that a lot of artistic people who go
into hollywood don't have great
relationships with their fathers
generally speaking i think that's more
typical not always the case i think it's
a reaction of feminism because feminists
for a long time were claiming
proclaiming that you shouldn't show
women as being stupid but that only
leaves the guys yeah i think there's
truth in that too but even if you go
back to the honeymooners which i would
say is before feminism had saturated the
culture as much the husband was still
sort of weak and stupid and very lucky
to have his wife yeah but he would
always threaten a beat that's true
that's true right so they removed they
did soften these types of characters
with feminism but there is this
interesting trope of like dad being a
hapless fool
simpsons i absolutely have to shout out
futurama
dad the white fun american dead is dumb
well no no in futurama they go to the
moon and it's a thousand years in the
future
and uh they're they're watching the
honeymooners and it's like one of these
days bang zoom straight to the moon
and then leela is like i didn't realize
21st 20th century astronauts were so fat
and then fry's like is that an astronaut
and he was just using beating his wife
as a metaphor for uh he was using space
travel as a metaphor for beating his
wife
i'm wondering if in all this division of
family in the soviet union when they did
it were there kids that
basically had their beliefs shattered
and then reformed and then at some point
realized maybe even too late like what
have we done as the government turns on
them like are these people that are like
useful pawns are they turned on
eventually oh yeah i mean then stalin
turned on the secret police and then he
turned on the top of the military which
was a major problem world war ii because
all these military geniuses were killed
another thing that they taught in the
soviet union very famously was the story
of pablo marozov who was this little boy
whose dad was doing was like
hoarding grain
and he turned his dad into the
authorities and his dad killed him this
is a completely made-up story but he
there were statues built to him and like
songs about him because you're taught in
school if your parents are doing
something wrong you have to inform on
them and if you're killed you basically
become a saint this is the greatest
thing you can do michael do you watch
anime god no you need to watch attack on
titan i i disagree with that i've never
heard the word need used more
incorrectly
and so there's a meme of like an ai
jordan peterson saying watch attack on
titan
and you know why amazing because he
wanted itunes
i don't actually expect you to watch it
so i'm just going to spoil the gist of
it for you it's already spoiled it's
anime yeah so the the first season
first you're gonna you're gonna love
this the first season oh yeah one more
thing i just got to say the only
cartoons i watch are freedom tunes thank
you so much much appreciated the first
season is uh
there's this the last city it's
surrounded by three walls and there are
giant humanoid monsters called titans
that eat people yeah i've seen the
preview yeah and they're invincible what
it's really about is that there was a
great nation that somehow came into the
power to become titans and use it to
conquer the world eventually the nation
crumbles i'm not to spoil too much and
now in the future these people are
effectively in a prison to pay the sins
of their ancestors in the mainland where
some of these people are called aliens
still live the the now dominant country
says you're evil because of what your
ancestors did and so you're they're
forced to live on reservations and then
they're they're basically treated like
second-class citizens people say like
whenever they come in a situ like a
situation with someone they're like yeah
well you you have the evil blood within
you so there's a scene where a kid turns
his parents in because they're trying to
rebel against the government because you
know they refused they believe in the
greatness of of themselves and things
like that there's a whole bunch of
themes that that talk about a lot of
what we're going through with sins of
the father uh white privilege
gulags and all of that stuff and that's
what the show is really about and so at
first i was like i gotta be honest when
when someone told me it's about people
who like use these ropes to fight giants
i'm like i really don't want to watch
that yeah and then when the robot jordan
peterson said got to watch attack on
titan or you can do python you have to
watch it on right now watch attack on
titan embody the archetypal hero sit on
your couch so i watched it yeah and then
it's like
it's it's crazy how there's like one
scene where there's two little girls
and uh one little girl's mother was
killed and but she's the evil race and
so then the not eat like the perceivably
you know the the one girl she's like
your people are evil and your mother
deserves to die and she's like why my
mother didn't do anything to anybody and
she's like because of your blood and
it's just
it's brutal man the show's so cool and
then there's like people zipping around
and fighting giants so i guess that's a
plus but there's also like that reminds
me of a fantastic planet which is uh you
know a movie about like the giants
calling humans as pets and it said it's
a
parable for czech slovakia and the
soviet uh occupation oh wow
was that how they were treating the
checks because you would love this movie
ian because this is the most like like
uh psychedelic movie like it's made by
paper cut outs you've probably seen the
iconography what's it called fantastic
fantastic planet thank you
there's no way you won't love this movie
oh wow and if what's really crazy is if
you watch a certain version it's dubbed
but the subtitles don't match the
dubbing there's slightly different
translations so you're watching it's a
complete it squeezes your head
completely interesting it's interesting
how stuff like that works in a cinema
like the idea that godzilla is actually
a metaphor for nuclear weapons yeah yeah
was it yeah oh yeah and it's and it's go
jira gojira well i'm sorry tim uncle
culture half asian you know i was just
doing in april in case you haven't heard
i was just doing an april fool's joke of
course it's go jira as a as a factoid
it is gojira but because with the
japanese people were saying gojira
americans thought it was an accent for
godzilla wasn't jackie gleason in the
first movie was he or orson welles it
was some major person was in the first
movie first godzilla yeah it is kind of
crazy that there was a show where like
the joke was he was going to beat his
wife and the audience would laugh yeah
i'm going to beat my wife bogart used to
smack women in the movies and people be
like i love him that's the best
performance a lot less back talk in
those movies yeah it's very cultural
truth hey i wanted you brought up april
fools i wanted to give you a little
history yeah an april fools day
well i'm just going to say whatever
you're about to say it's probably
contestants probably knows because no
one knows don't trust me did you look up
snopes no
i don't believe it from
check those from marca.com i've never
heard of it
yeah it's quick uh thought that april
fools dates thought came from about 1582
as france changed from the julian
calendar to the gregorian calendar uh
april 1st was the first day of the year
in the julian calendar and then when
they changed it to january they started
making fun of you said probably making
fun of people that still lived under the
julian calendar as they're all now
gregorian so i and i mentioned that
before we started the show i mentioned
that before starting the show my
citation was an episode of the simpsons
so that's i i also wanna i'm gonna do
one thing um
for everybody who's listening
put a one in the chat if you think that
michael malus will finish the whole
pizza by himself i'm not going to fish
the pizza but is he lying is he lost the
question i'm not there's no way i'm
finishing this
hit the like button if you think he's
lying there we go
also if you think he's telling the truth
and send it yeah also hit the like
button and send
dude michael how is austin i gotta ask
you i gotta know i i am so
so so happy every day in austin i can't
even begin to tell you and i'll give you
a rundown of reasons why first of all i
didn't realize to what extent living in
i was just in la last weekend signing
hardcovers i didn't realize to what
extent living in new york i had this
background music of anxiety and tension
yeah and i don't have any of that in
austin second austin is such a venn
diagram of different scenes making it
happen and everyone is very collegial
like they all get together and you you
when you meet people you're friendly in
new york when i would go to an event or
meet someone i'd have to bite my tongue
like who is this person are they gonna
be annoying are they gonna smiling out
to my face then go on twitter and blast
me there's none of that in austin
there's things i missed the restaurant
scene it's not what it could be austin
closes down early there's no like diners
so if it's like 1am you want to get a
bite you go to ihop which was a
situation
but i am turning my house into like this
get-together space so that all the
people coming through can i throw these
little events everyone can meet each
other and hang out and it i did only one
so far and it's worked absolutely
swimmingly
i have a question do diners in new york
city take reservations no
oh
i don't get it so i had a tweet that
went viral on reddit the left was
attacking me because i said i went to a
diner and they sat someone before me so
i got mad and left and they were just
like tim paul doesn't know what
reservations are and then a diner and
this but the reason i asked us i was
like maybe maybe the people who are
sharing all of this live in new york and
like new york is so crowded that they
would take reservations at diners too
man they're just dumb
yeah i guess so
i worked at like a nice diner it wasn't
a diner that's a thing it was a french
canadian restaurant that served
diner-ish but really high-end food and
we definitely took reservations but it
wasn't a diner you know it wasn't like
you know you get your diner food you're
7.95 there is a restaurant in new york i
don't know if it's survived kovid called
diner um but i they did take
reservations but obviously that one you
meant
yeah i've been to some i've never been
to a diner that took reservations it was
the weirdest thing to me when the left
was like tim poole's so dumb he doesn't
know what a reservation is and i was
like drew bro we're in a diner like you
walk in and there's like one like
haggard old lady with a cigarette going
wait do you want to sit
no should go sit anywhere you want honey
well no they were like there's a wait
there's a 20-minute win and then i was
like okay and then they sat actually two
groups before us and i was like okay i'm
leaving like i'm not and then i tweeted
about it kind of as like a half joke
because like you know i just tweet as to
be silly but also because i was making a
point about being a disagreeable person
on on petty petty [ __ ] as and the
point being that uh it helps you in
business being disagreeable especially
on petty things you don't want to be a
dick to people but if you're unwilling
to compromise for small things then
you'll tend to get better deals you and
you have to establish your own
boundaries too because i'll give you an
example this this actually happened
i flew
to
la because i was being interviewed for
some hbo documentary uh which i'll get
it to it that's a future date
and they were dragging their feet about
booking my planes so i'm like i'll just
do it myself you guys can pay me back
i booked the flight i get back i do a
killer interview they really liked it
great
and they're like all right um before you
get reimbursed you need to fill out this
like w2 or w9 and i go you have all the
information you need you have my paypal
address and you have the receipt you can
choose to pay me back or not that's your
prerogative i'm not doing one more thing
and they were like well we have to i'm
like you have i've i've said my pieces
on yes disgust they paid me but that's
the kind of thing where that was me
being very very petty but it's amazing
how companies will make you jump through
hoops
even when you're helping them and i'm
very big on
really being obnoxious about it and
drawing line ahead of time because
otherwise they'll just keep asking for
more and more oh i totally agree yeah i
i why wouldn't they i yeah the machine
craves profit why wouldn't they leverage
leverages everything leverages
everything so you go into a business
meeting if if you go in with a mentality
of desperation and need you've lost 100
but
if you genuinely need
well that's your position so you know
i've been position positions where i go
into a business meeting knowing like if
i don't get this deal i'm screwed and i
walk in and i'm like what do you have to
offer and they'll be like we're going to
pay you this much and i'll be like make
it a little bit more and they go okay
i'm like all right thank you very much
i've been in business meetings where i
didn't need anything from them and i
walk in they're like we want to pay you
you know 100 000 i'd be like give me a
half million and they go we can't afford
that i'll go well thank you for your
time yeah you know it's you've got
nothing for me yeah when you go into a
meeting or
interview or whatever you want to ask
them what what can you give me can you
give me what i need even if you you're
the one desperately in need don't let
them know that you you put them on the
defensive and you ask them if they can
give you the things that you need and
let me say one more thing kids if the
filthy hippie is telling you to walk in
the business meeting and say give me
give me give me you know it's coming
from a place of truth psychedelic
the
my favorite
one of my fav favorite bits of advice i
gave to somebody is i uh they got a job
offer at a company i worked at is advice
and
i told my friend like hey i'm putting in
a good word for you i could use your
help tell them you want this job he said
okay he emails
he messaged me back saying hey i'm not
going to take the job they're only
offering me 60k a year and i said
uh well how much do you want and he was
like i don't know i don't really want
the job and i said okay would you do the
job for 80 and he goes no i said would
you do the job for 19. he was no like
would you do the job for 120 and he goes
well 120 yeah and i was like so that's
what that's your answer email back
there's no no in business it's just
terms and he was like you want me to
email back telling him to double their
offer and i was like you don't want the
job any what's your worst case scenario
you don't get a job you didn't want
right and he was like oh okay he emailed
him and they were like we appreciate
your response but we're unable to pay
that much and he was like okay and then
i was like what was your worst case
scenario and he's like nothing right and
they came to me and they're like your
friend asked for a lot of money and i
was like yeah he didn't really want the
job no it's like
but but in their heads your friend is
worth a lot of money right they're going
to reach out to me next time instead of
being now they're going to know what his
price is exactly so it'll save everybody
a lot of time so here's what i love
asking people i probably i think i've
brought this on the show a year ago or
so uh
michael
if you got a phone call tomorrow morning
from mcdonald's corporate hq and said
michael we want you to run the cash
register at our uh
des plaines illinois location off of you
know 355 or wherever i don't know what
would you say to them
no
for you it might be
i i would be reticent or reluctant to
say wrong answer but
that is typically the wrong answer in
business there's i don't think there's
any amount of money i would do that for
because i meant i would it's not the
money that's the issue i'd have to
sacrifice my entire career or what i'm
working towards that's why i say for you
yeah but for the average person the
answer is how much yeah right give me
200 a year yeah 200. but for a lot of
people that's i mean they would take
that they would gladly do it i was going
to say less i was going to tell
mcdonald's you want 100 grand to work
the register most people are gonna be
like yeah but then you gotta move
that's true you know and that's very
expensive not to have friends and it's
it's business is all just about the
terms and the leverage you're willing to
to make so though the more you're
willing to sacrifice the more leverage
you have the more you win so if you're
like look buddy i'm willing to sleep on
a park bench
and i got nothing to lose you're paying
me what i want or you're not getting me
they're going to be like oh man i guess
we have to
some people have families or they go i
guess we really don't want them yeah
fine whatever and then go sleep on a
bench i actually don't believe this
happened to me i had was working i had a
meeting with a celebrity when i was
doing my co-authoring stuff and we
really really hit it off um and
i you know i had my standard fee and
they came back with half of it and in
retrospect i have to appreciate that
that was their move it's like oh yeah
you're asking for x how about half x
what have they got to lose right i was
livid and i don't even remember if i
took that project or not or if i know i
know i didn't know you know what i do i
don't respond to them oh yeah i actually
snapped at one of the biggest radio
like biggest production companies and
like distributors in the world they i
had this big business meeting i'm in a
room with like 10 people and i don't
want to give away too much information
for the sake of their privacy because
they work with some people people like
very very famous personalities they sent
me a contract with the most insane and
ridiculous terms i'd ever seen
and i responded back with this is this a
joke please if you'd like to do a deal
with me come back with a real contract
and they said this is normal in business
you would hire an attorney who would
amend the contract and i said if you
think i'm gonna spend five grand to
correct your your [ __ ] it's not
happening and so
i just said feel free never to email me
again because i'm not gonna waste my
time one second further yeah that
happened to me not that long also where
there's some congressman from brooklyn i
forget his name his chief of staff just
emailed me he's like oh we'd love to
have a congressman on your show great i
go how about like
one hour on monday we could talk about
his background because he had an
interesting background and they go oh
he'd only be available for 20 minutes
and how about on wednesday it's like i
have an hour-long show i didn't respond
it's just like you're pushing him onto
my show and then you want me to
restructure the whole show for you who
the hell are you you know but there's
there's something about
not being joe rogan i guess to use it
for lack of a better analogy where these
people think you're willing to take this
because we get we get hit up fairly
often from people who are like can i ask
you do you think it's that not being joe
rogan or the fact that they're so
oblivious to how podcasting works and
how the internet works that they really
don't think in terms of cma hits maybe
but i'm pretty sure if they reached out
to joe and joe was like i'd love to have
on the show they would say tell us how
you know where to jump and how high like
just let us know here's why i think
you're wrong because when i when the new
write came out in i believe 2019 i got
booked to do rogan and i got booked to
do reuben who was very big at the time
both of them obviously and i asked my
publisher if they had money for travel
which not they don't always do and
that's fair and they put told me in
writing this the head of publicity no
they can do skype
so this is 2019. and the idea that i got
unbroken to promote this book and i'm
going to call him up hey joe we're doing
skype is so
removed from what is you and i would
regard as normal are saying that a lot
of times i have to wonder what planet
these people are on it's true but we've
gotten hit up by people who uh
work in a similar space and they'll be
like hey this celebrity this this
prominent personality can come on your
show but you'll have to pre-record or
move your schedule and i'm like
you guys work in the same industry and
you know what else they don't realize is
a lot of these people that are maybe big
names for people who read okay magazine
if that's the whole thing you're not
going to get the big numbers having them
on the show because it's going to be
vanilla they're not going to say
anything interesting and it's going to
be like people tune in but you're not
going to have the traction exactly they
think because they get a bunch of views
on their platform which was provided for
them by someone else who built it that
you're lucky to have them on your show
to collaborate with them it's like well
but they're not interested thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you